. Now, I didn't even want to do this today,
but I sort of I sort of half.
Do, because there is a problem.
In the progressive community, Sam Ceder, host
of the Majority Report with Sam Ceder and
other shows with Sam Cedar, is doubling down
on his allegation that something is wrong
with the growth that our YouTube channel is
experiencing.
Now, two weeks ago, we reached 900000 subscribers
on our YouTube channel.
And I announced a race against the clock,
meaning I wasn't involving anybody else.
I wasn't assailing anyone's character.
I wasn't disparaging anybody's work.
I was challenging myself and you.
I was challenging the audience.
Can we get to a million YouTube subscribers
by Election Day?
At the time I said it, we were projected by
Social Blade, which is a Web site that tracks
this sort of thing to get to a million subscribers
by January nine.
We were scheduled to miss Election Day, thanks
to your support over the last two weeks.
The growth curve has accelerated.
And instead of January 9th, instead of December,
we are now scheduled to get to a million subscribers
on November twenty third, which means we're
down to just 20, 20 more days that we can
move that up and we will hit a million by
Election Day.
Well, Sam Ceder, who's also in this kind of
area between nine hundred thousand and a million
subscribers, he seems to think I'm cheating.
He seems to think I'm doing something wrong.
And he suggested last week that I might be
using bots or some other kind of mechanism,
elements of cheating for lack of a better
term, to get to a million subscribers.
He's fallen a bit behind in the race.
OK.
And he's now lashing out.
He's doubling down on these wild claims.
He he actually seems a little bit unhinged.
Check this out.
And remember, we're just kidding around.
This is all in good fun.
Remember that that you don't actually have
to email me or him about this.
But take a look at what Sam said.
Bear at home, too.
Great seeing you on MSNBC over the weekend.
Where can I find a full episode online so
I can send it to my mom?
Also, you're doing an impression of Chris
Hayes.
Your Caden's seem very familiar, like the
old man on Thursday is going to interview
David Pakman on one of the shows.
We're in a big war right now with David Pakman.
I know people know that.
So no way.
No way.
Well, what if he gives you views by being.
I got to see this stuff.
Yeah, well, so that that's a pretty low blow.
I don't have a history of stealing anything.
And by the way, this is not zero sum.
You know, you can subscribe to his channel
and mine.
Sam's problem is he's operating in the paradigm
of a zero sum world where you're either subscribed
to him or subscribe to me.
He thinks if I get a subscriber, I've taken
something from him that's maybe rightfully
his or something like that.
People can subscribe to both of us.
There's no way to steal subscribers.
And this diatribe and screed actually continued.
You know, with the way Pacman works, you just
come on to steal subscribers.
I know the way that he like what he's up to.
Can we get into this right now?
This is like I want to.
I've been trying to hold off on this, but
there's something fishy going on.
We're gonna do a deep, deep dove into this.
At one point would David Pakman subscriber
numbers because, you know, normally.
Subscriber numbers go like this.
All right.
They normally go like this.
That's the normal graph of subscriber numbers.
OK.
It's also my notes to myself.
You had a segment to do this.
Let me tell you what has happened with David
Pakman numbers.
They have gone like this.
Something very fishy is going on.
That is not a normal subscriber growth.
It's Ben Shapiro's way to sabotage you.
He's like getting in on there.
Well, I don't know what it is, but I'll tell
you this.
I suggested very lightly, very lightly that
maybe there were bots at play.
And then all of a sudden I get a bunch of
e-mails.
Saying I'm not a bot, but they do, but they
also are clearly sent from bots.
Look at those players.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Look at what's going on there.
I'm sorry, folks like what did.
What is that about?
There's something going on.
I think somebody should investigate this.
So this is I. I hate to say it, but this is
very Trumpy and of Sam.
This is a post hoc rationalization.
Sam is first looking at subscriber growth
on my channel.
And then he is after the fact.
Coming up with an explanation that points
to subterfuge.
It points to something untoward.
It can't just be, hey, people are connecting
with the content and they're subscribing.
That couldn't possibly be it.
It can't be if our growth is faster than Sam's.
I must be cheating.
And this got even uglier.
Well, do we have a clip of when he he as far
as I can tell, he got a subscriber's because
he attacked me.
Let's play this clip here.
Listen.
How do we even do this?
Things are getting really ugly in the progressive
media space.
And it pains me to have to do this today.
But Sam Ceder.
Has casually made a disgusting claim about
the David David Pakman show and fired a shot
across the bow about our recent surge of subscribers
claiming absent any evidence.
Mind you, that somehow bots that I have presumably
used or paid for are boosting our YouTube
subscriber numbers.
Let me give you a little background.
Last week, by the way, this is all a joke.
Just because I know people well, this is all
a joke.
Okay.
Last week I stopped The David Pakman Show
hit.
Not now.
What does he what is he doing there?
He's trying to play it off like it's all a
joke.
That's crazy.
Suing him, huh?
Well, I mean, I'm I'm I'm not suing him, but
I am going to look and see if there's any
type of.
Is it me?
Did Pacman sit in there basically calling
me a joke?
Right.
Didn't you just say it's all a joke?
I think he's worried that you might go off
the deep end and sue him.
Really?
Like, you know, right now, you could snap
any minute and just send him a cease and desist.
Shut down the show.
It be cool.
Here's my challenge.
David Pakman.
OK.
He just accused me of being a joke.
Right.
Like the whole video is about it, he just
said, this is this is all a joke referring
to me.
And so I as far as I'm concerned, that's that
libel or defamation?
Defamation, right.
When you said when you say it as opposed to
libel is written result.
Right.
Now, I know you guys are too smart to be goaded
into some kind of conflict here.
You all see what's going on.
I see what's going on.
We're not going to fall for it.
These bizarre semantic games, philosophical
black holes that people are great weren't.
We're just not going to bite.
What is is what is what is this subscriber
count data.
Experts look into it.
What is the subscriber count at nine thirty
to nine thirty two.
The guys added like 30000 subscribers in like
a week for Dunn, 17 to fifteen.
I thought we were tied with him two weeks
ago.
This is bad news.
Really bad.
So there you hear what this is really about.
You hear that in Sam's voice, right?
There is a frustration there that is being
taken out on me.
It's being taken out on you.
As one of my viewers or listeners, you were
called a bot.
So this we cannot allow join the David Pakman
show, YouTube channel.
Join the Pacman to one million by Election
Day 2020 campaign.
Subscribe today, it's free.
But in reality, let's get multiple shows on
the progressive left to a million subscribers.
You all know what to do.